[Music]
tonight a special edition of Brian Ross
investigates the behind-the-scenes
stories of some of America's best
investigative journalists the reporter
who exposed special treatment for a
politically connected billionaire
alleged to have sexually abused
dozens of teenage girls they were made
to believe that they were prostitutes
the reporters who expose children dying
in a special heart surgery unit in far
greater numbers than any other Hospital
in the state many ways these were
families who didn't have a voice and the
reporters across the country who exposed
public officials behaving badly the
sheriff in Alabama keeping government
money that was supposed to buy food for
his jails inmates he's probably the only
person who watched Shawshank Redemption
and was inspired by the warden that's
who he seems like the mayor of Baltimore
getting big bucks for a children's book
with embarrassing misspellings and a
shout-out for the high school
journalists who put aside their grief to
report on their classmates killed by a
student government these budding
journalists remind us of the media's
unwavering commitment to bearing witness
even in the most wrenching of
circumstances from the law and crime
Network studios in New York City's
Herald Square this is a special edition
of Brian Ross investigates good evening
and welcome tonight we feature the work
of some amazing journalists from across
the country who often don't get the kind
of recognition they deserve they face
challenges that make their work all that
much more impressive and we begin with a
shout out to the Miami Herald for its
explosive investigation into the special
treatment for a convicted billionaire
sex offender implicated in the abuse of
dozens of underage girls today a
shout-out to the Miami Herald for its
explosive investigation into how this
billionaire convicted sex offender
Jeffrey Epstein was able to get what was
essentially a slap on the wrist for
abusing dozens of underage girls we
didn't really know how many there were
I mean part of this story is how much
was kept secret in in the court
documents reporter Julie Brown spent
more than a year tracking down the young
women
were Epstein's victims I probably spoke
with about eight and of those eight only
four wanted to go on the you know
courageous enough to go on the record in
a powerful video Brown produced with her
partner Emily miss show we were underage
we were little girls I was 16 I was 16 I
started going to him when I was like 14
15 14 turning 15 if you think at 14 $200
that's a lot of money at 14 years olds I
mean that's a lot of money now and then
Brown spent countless hours doing
journalism the old fashioned
tried-and-true way to learn about the
lenient deal federal prosecutors cut
with Upstate requiring him to serve only
13 months in the county jail these are
10 to 12 years worth of documents there
was probably thousands if not tens of
thousands of documents to wade through
but the turning point came Brown says
when two key police officials trusted
her enough to lay out what really
happened behind the scenes
it started out giving me in a back road
but many cases it turned into something
far worse than that elevated to a crime
and a serious crime what he had a plane
to was a joke the sentence he served it
was even a bigger joke and then his
probation was a slap in everybody's face
I think once the police chief was
willing to go on the record with me and
the lead detective both of them had
never given interviews before and I
think after we did their interviews we
really realize how how good of a story
we had and it went to the heart of how
much influence Epstein had and how he
and his the people that work for him
bullied everyone associated with this
case and look who knows what else is
going to come out I mean that the
excellent journalism is now has spread
the message it's not just a state court
case that's stuck in Palm Beach County
now people are really aware of what's
going on Browns reporting raise
questions about the federal prosecutor
at the time Alex Acosta who is now the
Secretary of Labor in the Trump
administration
he seemed to go to great lengths to cut
a lenient deal with Epstein and keep the
whole process secret according to brown
Acosta defended the deal during his
Senate confirmation hearings this that
mr. Epstein should plead guilty to two
years register as a sex offender and
concede liability so that victims could
get restitution and if that were done
the federal interest would be satisfied
and we would defer to the state Brown
got no comment from Epstein nor did we
but one of his lawyers Alan Dershowitz
told me he was proud of the deal he made
for his client so no regrets then and
arranging a deal in which he spent only
13 months spent only 10 months I mean
the job of criminal defense lawyers to
get the best possible deal if I had been
able to get him a deal where he spent no
time in prison that would have been even
better members of Congress have now
asked for a full investigation of the
deal in the wake of Julie Browns
reporting and she is continuing on the
story knowing that her efforts made a
difference and gave Epstein John victims
a sense of justice that the Department
of Justice did not they were made to
believe that they were prostitutes so
they finally said someone's finally
understanding that we weren't
prostitutes we were girls he violated us
maybe now something will change I think
they're still hoping for for a sense of
justice that something will be done in
the case so a shout out to Julie Brown
and since her initial report Congress
has launched his own investigation and
the federal judge handling the case
issued a ruling saying the federal
prosecutors involved acted illegally in
cutting the deal for Epstein
next another story that had a huge
impact from an investigative team at the
Tampa Bay Times who took a tip from a
hospital employee and discovered
children in a special harp surgery unit
dying at an alarming rate the
investigative report with its own video
was aptly named heartbroken at least 11
children dead in one 18-month period
many others left paralyzed
or otherwise harmed surgeons actually
left a needle inside this girl's heart
and never told her parents it's the best
Hospital that's the best place you can
be you're the best hands in Florida and
we find that there was in fact the
needle in her chest and after the
surgery was over when they did the count
they have to do to make sure they have
all the utensils and everything they
were missing a needle so they knew they
were missing the needle but they never
said anything to us it was that
troubling story that the reporters at
the Tampa Bay Times say made them
certain they were onto something big I'm
Kathleen McCrory
I'm the deputy investigations editor for
the Tampa Bay Times and I'm Neal Betty I
am an investigative reporter for the
temporary Times the reporters say the
initial tip came from someone who worked
at the Children's Hospital which had
been taken over by the prestigious Johns
Hopkins Medical Center it's promotional
videos boast of a world-class reputation
they came in and told us that she had
truncus arteriosus they told us we'd be
going to Johns Hopkins all Children's
[Music]
they just kept telling us that there
wasn't a story here for a little while
and that they had self police themselves
out of their problems so there was no
point in us further investigating or
researching what was going on but
McGrory and Biddy ignored all that and
dug deeper into what happened at the
hospitals Heart Institute after Hopkins
had taken over after that happened there
started to be some serious clinical
issues in the program and that meant
that children were dying at a much
higher rate and there were far more
complications than this program was used
to it had tripled to about nine or ten
percent and that was the highest rate of
any program in Florida that we had seen
for the past decade and then using
social media as a starting point the
reporters began to hear from families
whose children had been at the Heart
Institute it was incredibly emotional I
mean the families were we're devastated
when they found out that what happened
to them didn't happen in isolation you
know that there were other families who
had experienced the same thing no family
more devastated than the Eskimo yes
doctor came
he goes you know mr. Escamilla you know
I just know something about I really
hate to tell you but your daughter just
suffered a stroke
I just remember looking at I just burst
out crying
the reporters uncovered one
heartbreaking case after another yeah in
many ways these were families who didn't
have a voice and in particular they
didn't have a voice alone you know but
when they came together they had much
more of a voice the full Tampa Bay Times
investigative report told a story that
son in the hospital had tried to keep
quiet you know it was only a few weeks
before they made pretty system-wide
changes to the hospital the CEO resigned
we saw three vice presidents resign two
surgeons left the hospital two heart
surgeons the chairman of surgery stepped
down from that post although he remains
at the hospital and the new hospital
President issued a remarkable apology to
the families and the employees who had
tried to blow the whistle I know
personally that many of you courageously
spoke out when you had concerns but were
ignored or turned away that behavior is
unacceptable and will not be tolerated
going forward and most importantly we
know an apology to the families and
patients who did not receive the
high-quality care that is our promise to
all patients I am deeply sorry for their
tragic losses it is devastating when a
child is harm or life dis lost for the
two reporters the profuse Hospital
apology served as a confirmation that
they were right to pursue the story in
the first place and they say there is
still more to do as we saw the stories
had great impact including a new state
law that increases oversight of
children's heart surgery programs so was
shout out to the 10th of a time's up
next on our special report the reporters
who focus too light on local officials
who tried to cash in on their jobs and I
sincerely want to say that I am
conscious
[Music]
something to accept the people the
people of Baltimore
we're back now with our special report
on journalists whose works we have
highlighted this year included an
investigative reporter in Alabama who
discovered a County Sheriff was
personally pocketing government money he
did not spend on food for prisoners
Sheriff Todd and Rickon quickly
denounced the stories as faked news a
political smear over the past two weeks
me my family my office the citizens
vetted wall county have been targets of
miscellaneous fake news stories but
reporter connor sheets of al.com
says he was confident he got it right
standing behind his stories and a video
describing nightmare conditions at the
Gadsden Alabama jail and detailing how
some of the money for food ended up in
the sheriff's personal bank account but
we know that he kept over 2.5 million
dollars become but we only really have
snippets based on which documents I was
able to obtain the story was picked up
across the state and around the country
and Alabama sheriff was defiant today as
he defended his practice of pocketing
leftover money from the inmates food
budgets he's taken in well more than
$250,000 a year the most he's required
to report it rich material for the link
he's probably the only person who
watched Shawshank Redemption and was
inspired by the warden that's what he
seems like sheet says former prisoners
in jail employees told him the sheriff
was cutting food costs with food that
was donated rotten or worse a meat
product that would come in it was kind
of gray and drab and some of them want
some of them called it's starfish
patties they said it looked like a
starfish once it was chopped up but
essentially it was wrapped in a in a
plastic wrapping sort of like a you know
like a roll sausage and they're not
wrapping and the box that it came in
both said in red bold letters not fit
for human consumption the sheriff said
prisoners should not expect anything
more than three square meals a day now
let me be clear this is a jail
this is not a bed-and-breakfast Domino's
does not deliver here we don't run to
McDonald's and get these prisoners or
Chinese Big Macs wow I think this guy
knows how to run a prison but he knows
his fuss food restaurant say yeah you as
he was describing his meal plan for
himself that's what it sounded like
we're not gonna get you the crispy bacon
later with the cheese and we're not
gonna get you the mac Florrie with Oreo
swirl or the Arby's meat Mountain now
that one's off menu so you gotta ask for
it we're not gonna Darrell but the
biggest reveal came when she's reported
it was all legal under an arcane state
law that makes the sheriff personally
responsible for feeding his prisoners
it's the law I'm not having done
anything wrong and it's the end of the
day if you make a profit it's yours
she's reporting found that may be true
with state money but not necessarily
with the money the federal government
pays to house immigration detainees at
the state level the governor has already
changed the policy for the state the
state legislators are looking now to
push me laws and there's been
investigations launched at the federal
local and state levels so I think
whether or not it's legal at this time
is to some degree didn't beside the
point I feel like that just gives public
officials an incentive to do their jobs
badly like I don't think it would be a
good idea so that firefighters keep any
money they save on water
you know for all the jokes Connor sheets
investigation was a serious look at an
often underreported condition involving
local jurors sheet says he is far from
true with his investigation which last
week was named one of the finalists for
the prestigious Goldsmith award at
Harvard University and since the
reporting of Connor sheets the Alabama
governor has signed into law a bill that
would prevent sheriff's from keeping
state jail food funds next a shout-out
for the reporter in Baltimore who
answered a phone call with a tip on a
Sunday afternoon and began to track a
scandal that has now led to the
resignation of the city's mayor the FBI
searching the home and office of
embattled baltimore mayor they came out
of the house with boxes and boxes upon
evidence when the FBI raided the home of
baltimore mayor
catherine pugh it wouldn't have been
much of a surprise to the readers of The
Baltimore Sun at its Statehouse reporter
Luke Broadwater who has a good source
and a good nose for when something
smells fishy
and sometimes tips pan out and sometimes
they don't you know you chased and but
this time it resulted in something and
frankly I was personally very surprised
by how how strong and harsh the reaction
was and how quickly things began to
change the tip involved members of the
board of the University of Maryland
Medical Center giving themselves
lucrative deals but the center refused
to answer any of broad waters questions
so that as I like to say set off my
spidey sense and I said well why why do
you want to answer my questions you know
so I started calling around people in
the nose and soon broad water with the
help of other reporters documented how
the mayor who was on the board had
received some $800,000 for a series of
children's books healthy Holly many
which were never distributed or even
printed and we also know that thousands
of the books are sitting unread in a
warehouse
at the school system headquarters
because the school system says they
never asked for the books and they think
they're of not high enough quality to be
used for instruction so these books just
sort of showed up when the score says
school system's doorstep one day he
unasked-for unsolicited but the books
are good for lots of laughs it seems it
is hard to believe whose books were
bought purely on the base of literary
merit reporters who've read them have
pointed out that for a start she can't
seem to settle on the correct spelling
of the name for one of her main
character educational children's book
about eating right she spell vegetable
rock we do know the mayor had some books
in her house and her car never got to
any kids as saw during the FBI raid they
were carrying out many of the boxes of
the healthy Holly books before she
resigned mayor Pugh had offered an
apology to the people of Baltimore for
anything unethical
you want to say that I apologize that
done something to upset the people the
people of Baltimore and I love care
about and then she launched into a
bizarre three-minute pitch for her new
line of baby clothing for the son it has
been a story no other news outlet has
come close to matching was one of those
times when everybody in the newsroom
knows there's a big story so it's sort
of an all-hands-on-deck approach I mean
I think at different points probably
maybe 10 or more reporters have had a
byline on this story and serves as yet
another example of the value of robust
local reporting Lee I think like this
shows the Sun what the Sun at its best
and what the Sun can do yeah we we we've
we have covered something that nobody
knew was happening we exposed it and
there's been swift change and
ramifications that would never have
happened if it were not for a strong
local newspaper so the FBI investigation
continues in Baltimore as does the
reporting of the Baltimore Sun and Luke
Broadwater next a shout out from
students earnest who watched as their
fellow classmates were murdered and then
went to work as reporters when we return
we close out this special edition with a
shout out for all the reporters who won
Pulitzer Prizes this year and for a
group that did not win the Pulitzer
Prize but for whom the Pulitzer judges
went out of their way to honor right
before I announce who they are I want to
break with tradition and offer my
sincere admiration for an entry that did
not win but that should give us all hope
for the future of journalism in this
great democracy the entry is from the
staff of the Eagle Eye student newspaper
at Marjory Stoneman Douglas High School
in parkland Florida which submitted the
obituaries of 17 coaches and classmates
who were killed during a tragic shooting
in their school in February 2018 the
eagle-eyes submission stated that the
student reporters and editors had to
quote put aside our grief and recognize
our role as both survivors journalists
and loved ones of the deceased unquote
these budding journalists remind us of
the media's unwavering commitment to
bearing witness even in the most
wrenching of circumstances in service to
a nation whose very existence depends on
a free and dedicated press there is hope
in their example even as security
threats to journalists are greater than
ever and there is hope even if some
wrongly degrade the media as the enemy
of the very democracy it serves of
course the press will endure because as
the founding fathers knew well there can
be no democracy without it
that is something Rebecca Smith Wendy
Winters robbed hyacinth Gerald Fishman
and John McNamara understood too they
understood it when they went to work
last June at the Capitol Gazette in
Annapolis Maryland and were gunned down
by a madman who opened fire in their
newsroom it is what Jamal could show he
understood as well when he bravely wrote
truth to power at the Washington Post
before being murdered in October 2018
inside the Saudi consulate in Turkey in
all 63 professional journalists
worldwide were killed this year
according to reporters without borders
that is a 15% increase in journalists
who lost their lives for simply trying
to do their jobs and their spirit this
year's winning work reflects yet again a
steely resolve in upholding the highest
principles and ideals of this noble
profession yet what could often seem
like a dark time there do remain places
where the future of journalism seems
bright that's our program for tonight
we'll see you back here next week good
night